hey everyone what is going on we are
talking gran turismo 7. man i
am pumped for this i've been playing for
the past couple weeks full disclosure i
was actually involved i was co-hosting
the launch video for playstation's gran
turismo 7 regional launch here in
singapore but that does not shape my
opinion in any way shape or form for
this right these are my thoughts and my
thoughts only i mean because we know
gran turismo is an awesome game for 25
years it's just kicked ass right but how
good is gran turismo 7 and does it live
up to some of the claims that
playstation is wanting for people that
aren't hardcore gamers aren't hardcore
sim racers can you still enjoy gran
turismo 7. what are some of the facets
you may like if you just love cars and
you're not if you're not a big racer
we're here to talk about that right now
anyway with that let's get into talking
about gran turismo 7. now i played gran
turismo sport previously and you look i
love gran turismo sport it's fun you get
right into the action and you just start
building up your credits and building up
your points and it's fun to use and now
i don't have a wheel in my home i don't
have a sim in my home i'm using the dual
sense controller with my ps5 and i got
to tell you if you thought that was good
on gran turismo sport you are going to
be blown away with what it acts like
with the playstation 5. because dual
sense controllers i just want to put
this out there for those who aren't
hardcore gamers you're going to you're
going to be fine with the dual sense
controller right the gyroscope inside of
it is awesome it's accurate it is
responsive but the feedback the feedback
on the controllers i'm getting a little
ahead of myself in this review but trust
me the feedback on the controllers is
fantastic and you know when you're
playing other gran turismos with the
dual sense controllers right everything
vibrates and moves all as one right
right
but with ps5 and gran turismo 7 it's
different every move is specific if
you're in the left side if you're
getting to the left side you're going to
feel the left side of the controller if
you're hitting your brake or your air
your your gas you're going to feel that
acceleration you're going to feel the
braking you know shaking here and there
and if your brakes give out you're going
to feel that if you're on if you're
doing rally racing and you're on dirt
and your terrain it's all over the place
you're going to feel the skids it's
awesome to play with let's talk about
the world of gran turismo 7 and it all
basically is in the hub in the world map
you go to the gt cafe and this is where
it all starts and this is where it all
begins from and the gt cafe is the it's
your introduction to the world of gran
turismo and they do it in such a way
that if you're not a hardcore gamer
you're going to understand this because
it walks you through the history of
automobiles what each car stands for
what the history of each car is about or
manufactured for that matter uh
front-wheel drive rear-wheel drive for
four-wheel drive different classes of
cars it teaches you everything as you go
through these challenges the gt cafe
really just
it challenges you it's fun it's
enjoyable it's relaxing the whole way is
designed you've seen it in some of their
launch videos and you've probably seen
already some reviews on it it's really
cool and you go through these different
menu books in the cafe hence the cafe
you need a menu and you go and you can
do let's say collect these three cars
you get this you get some points you
open up some tracks go to the next level
the next level the next level and then
it'll say okay well you need a better
license than what you currently have so
then you have to go to the licensing
center et cetera et cetera and all these
challenges all start from there and for
me currently right now where i stand is
i'm on menu book 19 or 20 i forget one
of the two and i'm on i'm trying to
finish my uh super license exam i've
been on that uh track for the past few
hours
with uh not a lot of uh success even
trying to get the bronze because getting
a gold silver or bronze when you're
doing your licensing yeah it was really
tough but they did
sent out a patch recently to make it a
little bit easier to get the bronze and
i mean by a second easier because some
of the timings they wanted you to get in
your licensing were like
how the hell am i going to get this man
you've got to really be damn good at
racing and i'm pretty good right i'm not
too bad myself but it was like this was
stressful and it took me hours to do it
but in terms of that aspect of it it's
really fun and it's enjoyable and along
the way you do learn a lot about cars
and automobiles and collecting the cars
and when we go to the world circuit and
you're racing on these uh these tracks
around the world the graphics and the
detail we've got to talk about this
because this is where gran turismo 7
shines it's showcasing some of the best
that uh playstation has for the ps5
right now 4k 60 with ray tracing it is
fluid it is awesome to play with i
played in 4k 60 with ray tracing and i
played a 4k 30 with ray tracing
and because my tv doesn't do 4k 60 with
ray tracing right so it's beautiful guys
you are going to be
blown away by the reflections and how
light
affects things if you're going through a
tunnel and then you're hit you hit
sunlight the glare on your windshield
like you're driving it's there you can
tell i'm really excited but before we go
on here's a message from our sponsor
here at geek culture we love our
keyboards especially with the all-new
logitech mx keys mini an elegant and
functional keyboard its ultra responsive
rounded keycaps are super stable and
quiet for more productivity there are
buttons to enable dictation microphone
audio control and emojis the backlit
keys illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or 5 months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com
when you're in this world with the sound
that 3d audio sound that's inside of
this game if you have the headphones for
that you're going to love it but the
sound and the image quality blows your
mind
uh i mean i was really impressed i was
like i mean i thought gran turismo sport
was really good right
this is another level up it really is
then you got to take all those graphics
and you have to go into scapes mode
escapes mode is where you take
photographs of your cars now here's the
thing about escapes mode you need to
know you can only take photos of the
cars you have collected thus far
there's a demo which has a lamborghini
but outside of that only the cars that
you've collected thus far if you really
want some epic photos you got to collect
some cars
but the settings the backdrops there are
so many of them to choose from from all
over the world
i love car photography right i love
photography as a whole
this is a lot of fun this is like
lightroom and photoshop
in playstation you can really tweak your
image quite a bit i mean you can take
the car now you can't change the color
of the car inside scapes mode you can
only do that through the gt
auto section in the game i'll talk about
that in just a second where you can
customize everything there but in
escapes mode you can change the there's
various different lightings uh different
presets for the overall scene or for
your backdrop or for your car you can
mask things out you can really get into
your you know your various different
contrasts and bright points and
midpoints and you can black levels you
can play with that a little bit your
saturation you can move the car around
almost 360 you cannot go on top of the
car see from top down or kind of bottom
up you can't do that as of yet at least
from my experience but you can move the
car around turn it around you can move
it around the scene to place it where
you want to be you can put multiple cars
in a scene if you want to do that you
can have panning shots you can depict
how fast you want the car to be going
for your panty shot how much of the car
you want to be in focus
i'm telling you guys this is a
photographer's wet dream when it comes
to car photography in gran turismo 7.
i'll i probably know some people will
just buy this game just for that to be
honest with you because i know this kind
of photography this online gaming
photography is really capturing a market
out there and a segment and i can see a
lot of images can be going up on
instagram ig stories or whatever the
case is because
it's awesome man it is so damn cool it
is really cool so let's talk a little
bit more about uh
the cars some of the newer aspects to
gran turismo 7 you have actually access
to used cars now so you can purchase
used cars if you want to do that um and
also when it comes to tuning your car
you have a lot of tools at your disposal
and it teaches you along the way when
you're you're in the tuning center and
you're trying to figure out what how do
i tune my car what is each part for you
have different segments inside of that
you actually have a guide there that's
going to walk you through what each part
does and if you need a subsequent part
for that to make that all work in
harmony then if you want to go into
shopping for brand new cars you go to
brand central and it's this beautiful
showcase with all the different brands
there you can pick up all your new cars
depending on how many credits you have
then there's the legend cars aspect to
it we can pick up legendary classic cars
or new cars that are just you know the
rarest of the rare uh you can buy those
if you have the credits uh i mean
there's so many different modes in this
now of course playing in the beta
version i didn't have access to every
single let's say multiplayer function
modes or various different modes like
that or sports mode but in terms of
shopping i didn't have all the credits
to buy all these crazy cars yet i'm
working towards that but to see it and
to and understanding the other showroom
and there's videos inside of the
showroom there's lewis hamilton videos
there's other videos as well to teach
you about the cars and to teach you
about the brands it is
it's it's really cool and that's one
thing i love about what gran turismo 7
has done is that it's more of an
educational tool
but it also brings you on this journey
of auto racing and if you really want to
be a hardcore sim racer you're going to
love what it brings to you now
in terms of the racing aspects of the
game right that's everything's pretty
much done in the world circuits when
you're a single player mode
and it shows you your line which your
line you should hit where your breaking
point should be if you want need
assisted driving in that regard you can
do auto or you can do manual and it's
great that it has all those things and
you can turn it off at your disposal
whatever you want it to turn off uh but
it really does
make the experience a lot easier and a
lot more uh user-friendly for novices
out there and for me uh who hasn't
played a lot of racing games it was a
welcomed uh addition now of course i
have driven cars on a actual racetrack
before so i kind of understand my line
and where to hit the apex everything
else like that but um it's nice to have
it in the game because of the speeds
you're going the game with depending on
the car it does aid you in a lot of ways
but yeah i've really just enjoyed gran
turismo 7 a lot and it's been a game
that you know i've been really playing
for the past couple weeks really
hardcore almost every night now i'm
going to tone down a little bit because
i have a life and i got to do other
reviews for this channel and other
things for my personal work as well but
the escapes mode i can't wait to get
more cars and take photos of that and
share it up online that's going to be
awesome so what are some of the aspects
of gran turismo 7
that i wish were improved or could be
improved on well a couple things first
and foremost the number of cars
there's not that many cars considering
this is the 2022 game you would be
surprised how many cars are missing some
newer cars that are missing from various
different auto manufacturers out there
and this is uh it kind of threw me for a
little bit i mean small things but case
in point volkswagen for example right
the new gti is not there or any suv for
that matter it's still some of the older
cars that are there i mean the concepts
are there but you don't have some of the
newer stuff and even for other brands as
well too so they're missing some of the
newer cars so
perhaps they will be an upgrade to this
and they will add more cars in the
future i'm sure they will but as it
stands right now at launch
it could do with a little bit more cars
um also too if you are someone who's
played all the grand trees ones before
this and you have accomplished all these
points and
all the you nailed all your licenses
down and you are really a professional
driver a hardcore racer you have to
start from the beginning in gran turismo
7. there's no legacy mode where you can
actually let's say either carry over
your credentials so to speak or you
could take let's say your exams and your
various different licenses and once you
take that exam if you pass it it unlocks
everything
there's none of that so you're really
going to start from scratch some people
are okay with that and some people would
find that a little bit daunting i mean
for me personally when i was playing
gran turismo sport i was racking up some
good points and racking up some
experience and none of that carried over
whatsoever i had to start from scratch
with gt7 so that would be nice if that
was included
in the game so you didn't have to start
from the beginning but you know what
they say it is what it is but outside of
that i think gran turismo 7 is just a
fantastic game it's not even a game it's
a platform it's an automobile platform
history collectibility uh tunier cars
understanding racing
photography
the journey that you take in gta 7 is
really cool
and
i for one am a fan i didn't expect i
mean when i watched the launch video and
everything else i said okay this is
really interesting but when you get to
play it and you get to experience it
i mean i can just see myself just enjoy
myself hanging out for an afternoon for
a couple hours taking photos and sharing
them online or just reading about on
cars and watching some of the videos
inside the game and just learning a
little bit more about the industry as a
whole and gt7 is all that for you and if
you want to be the most hardcore sim
racer out there you can do that as well
anyway those are my thoughts on gran
turismo 7 let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below is the game
you picked up are going to pick up any
questions you have i will try to answer
those for you with that guys follow us
on facebook subscribe to us on this
channel like this video helps us out a
lot take care stay safe and we'll chat
to you soon